I'm an optimist like if something bad
happens tomorrow I would default into
thinking well I'm so grateful that I've
had it for this long yeah
instead of like why did it go away when
you face your fears and you look at them
you're so disappointed because it's not
a big deal
it's very simple once you face it the
question isn't can you handle the
situation the question is can you handle
your mind what's that believe nation
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference now I
started the belief life series to once a
week tackle a different topic outside of
just hardcore entrepreneurship and so to
help you live your best believe life
today we're gonna look at five
strategies to help you destroy your
fears for good also if you want to know
what Gary Vaynerchuk Tony Robbins and
Mel Robbins have to say about confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a 30 second to 5 minute
video for free every morning to help you
build unstoppable confidence the link is
in the description below on a bigger
macro
patience and failure they all ladder up
to one thing which is insecurity the
reason people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much all of us
have kind of an identity for ourselves a
way of defining ourselves and human
beings don't usually stray from that so
if you consider yourself to be a
conservative person or a shy person I
know the way you move to some extent I
know the facial expressions the gestures
that I use your body and it's all
consistent with the fact that human
beings our strongest Drive is the need
to stay consistent with how we define
ourselves you know I talk a lot about
being honest with yourself about what
you want and if you're somebody that's
watching this and you have no clue what
you want I'm gonna say that's total
[ __ ] I think you've probably decided
that either you can't have it because
you don't think you're smart enough or
good enough or worthy enough or maybe
you think you're too old or you've told
yourself that you can't make a living
doing it
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get confident with Gary Vaynerchuk
how do you deal with the unknown like
win it by recognizing I have no choice
right yeah like cuz that's actually life
like who the like zero people exist are
you scared like do you have a fear of
the unknown
nope like that's what my main thing it's
like with every aspect yep you have to
fit because I'm confident yeah like I'm
not scared because I know I can handle
anything you know and and I know I can
handle anything because I'm grateful
that for everything I've got
and I never envy and want anything else
and um you know driven by that and I'm
an optimist like if something bad
happens tomorrow I would default into
thinking well I'm so grateful that I've
had it for this long yeah
instead of like why did it go away a
hundred percent and you need to chip
away at that and you need to realize
what's practical not this is an insular
game every time you let somebody's voice
get into your head and their opinion or
what they're doing you'll become
insecure every time you're just about
you with yourself and just you you'll
win confidence is only about loving
yourself what about the politics of
everything they're real but a funny
thing happens when you're not listening
if you you know you you can hear your
brothers points of view you can hear
your mom's points of view you can hear
your roommates points of view you can
hear my point of view but like when
you're actually not listening you're not
listening I think everybody's trying to
like control that you can't control rule
number two
dance with your fear with Tony Robbins I
don't negotiate with my mind this I run
this is my heart and soul I don't let
the brain run I use my brain he'll let
my brain use me everybody has a place
where they get fearful it's just the
human mind it's there
it's not that you're not gonna be
fearful I think what it really is is
just again training yourself to say I
can be fearful and I can do it anyway I
don't have to get rid of the fear I just
have to dance with I have to use the
energy of it to move myself forward and
I found in the early days I used to like
when I try to make a decision I would do
what I called my rocking chair test I
took a helicopter ride one time we're
flying straight across all the people
bumper-to-bumper no stop this is the way
to live what would it take to you know
learn how to fly a helicopter money time
energy where I'm going to fit all this
in what would life be like I'm 85 years
old I'm in my rocking chair and I flew
helicopters and I took my friends and
family and took the doors off we
screamed down on the water we lived this
life where you could go wherever you
want the way you want it was like wow I
looked at what that life would be felt
it felt incredible and what if you never
learned what if you come up with all
these fears I don't have time one of the
money I don't know if I can do it I can
master it and you let the fears dominate
me and I never learn to fly a helicopter
I'm 85 in my rocking chair and I look
back on my life and I missed out on all
that but the fastest way to deal with
fear is do it anyway you don't have to
feel good to do stuff that's the
illusion make yourself do it what I've
trained my brain is what I say do it we
do it doesn't matter if it feels good
doesn't matter if it's too cold doesn't
matter if I don't feel like doesn't
matter if I'm fearful I do it anyway and
when you train yourself to do it anyway
you have a freedom most people never
have rule number three face the monster
under your bed with Patrick Bateman face
the monster on your bed let me tell you
what I mean by facing the monster under
your bed as kids some kids go to sleep
and they feel like there's a monster
under their bed like think about it I
was a kid I was afraid to put on my arm
out you know why because I thought there
was a monster under the bed I don't know
if you had this I was afraid of how my
legs out the blanket had to cover me I'm
telling you as a kid now that somebody
may say you're out of your mind some of
you may say that's that was me
I was afraid what if my leg is out a
monster pulls my lickers you would see
this you know my sister would
intentionally put nightmares on
Nightmare on Elm Street and call my gosh
Freddy Krueger could be coming out and
go to sleep dreaming about Freddy's
under your bed
Freddie what was that one song with
Freddie Freddie and I on how did it go
on - he's looking for you I'm sure
they're putting the song up for you to
hear that song screwed with my head in
Iran I was more scared of Freddy Krueger
than Saddam Hussein Iran and Saddam used
to bomb us all the time it doesn't
matter you gotta face it as simple as go
under your bed and realize there's
nobody there look in the in the shown
narcos the character steve murphey whom
i just said with a couple weeks ago
anyways interview is gonna come out here
pretty soon he says the following thing
and I think it's like season 2 episode
number 11 or something like that when
when they kill Pablo he says all that
time hunting him and just like that I'm
looking down at Pablo effing Escobar for
years I've been building up this son of
a [ __ ] in my head what a monster hit be
but here's the thing when you lay eyes
on him the devil's a real letdown just a
man
beer grown doesn't shave fat and
shoeless you know what his point is
Pablo was this big it was a devil he was
evil it can be taken down everyone was
afraid of him and then he's dead when
you face your fears and you look at him
you're so disappointed because it's not
a big deal it's very simple once you
face it for so many people they never
have that moment that Steve Murphy had
and in the show narcos or in real life
against pablo escobar they don't have it
so some people are 85 and that fear is a
reality because they never faced it rule
number four use anchor thoughts with Mel
Robbins if you've got to do something
that really makes you nervous or that
you're afraid to do before you're about
to do it come up with an anchor thought
what's an anchor thought well an anchor
thought is something that's going to
anchor you so that you don't escalate
any situation into a full-blown panic
attack or into a situation where you
screw things up it's a way for you to
anchor yourself so you maintain control
over what you're thinking and how you
behave so here's an example with flying
it's important when you're creating an
anchor thought to pick something that is
in the proper context of what you're
afraid to do so for flying pick an
anchor thought that has to do with
trip that you're taking so if I'm
boarding a plane to fly back home to
Michigan an anchor thought might be a
picture in my mind of my mom and I
walking on the shores of Lake Michigan
where I grew up that's a thought that
makes me happy it makes me excited and
it's also related to the trip that I'm
taking if you have a conversation that
you need to have with your boss pick an
anchor thought about how you feel after
having that conversation maybe it's you
picking up the phone and calling
somebody that you you love and saying oh
my gosh it went so well or you know you
walking out of the meeting and feeling
like yeah I survived that conversation I
feel pretty good about myself so now
that you have your anchor thought you're
ready to beat the fear how you're gonna
do it is this so let's go back to the
example of the plane I'm on the plane
and flying to Michigan we hit turbulence
my body's gonna start getting agitated
right I'm starting to get nervous my
heart starts to race one of two things
can happen I can't control how my body
might feel but I can always always
control what I'm thinking about and I
can always control how I act and so can
you
so when I'm on a plane and the
turbulence hits 5 4 3 2 1 that's step
one and it's essential and the reason
why using the five-second rule 5 4 3 2 1
is essential is because that is how you
switch the gears in your mind you awaken
your prefrontal cortex and you trigger
your brain that you're now in control of
your thoughts you've interrupted the
fear you've settled your thoughts and
now your brain is ready for that anchor
thought so then what I do after I go 5 4
3 2 1 is I insert the anchor thought
that I've already come up with before
the flight I start thinking about
walking on the beach and being with my
mom and my dad and I start telling
myself I'm so excited to walk on the
shores of Lake Michigan I'm so excited
to see my parents
now something remarkable is going to
happen in your brain because you've
interrupted the fear and because you've
used the five-second rule to assert
control and awaken your prefrontal
cortex and because you have an image
that contextually makes sense to your
brain because you're flying to Michigan
you know your brain does your brain goes
huh
that was excited to go to Michigan
because my body is in a state remember
the first fact fear and excitement exact
same thing what's the difference between
fear and excitement what your brain is
saying using the five-second rule and an
anchor thought you can actually switch
the gears in your mind and reframe the
thoughts of fear into thoughts of
excitement and because you have a vision
that makes sense based on what you're
doing
your brain buys it you just tricked your
brain and rule number five the last one
before very special bonus clip is manage
your mind with Will Smith something that
probably a lot of people don't know
about me I don't put the ocean the ocean
is like the ultimate woman she's
beautiful and she will nourish you but
she will tear you to shreds also
the ocean is my worst fear I don't know
what it is or where it came from but
there's something about not being able
to breathe
I've tried snorkeling before and I was
hyperventilating
my 50th birthday is this year I just
wasn't gonna go into the back nine of my
life without having attacked my fear the
ocean so we're about to scuba dive the
Great Barrier Reef you know I've never
scuba divin scoubidou scuba I never been
scuba divers before so we're taking a
boat ride out do we go through a storm
probably 25 years old in my mind I would
be here one day so I'm ready I'm ready
this is stupid I'm not going is it okay
to punch sharks in the face back up with
your shark ass back up with your shark
ass
shucks ass back up I got it the question
isn't can you handle the situation the
question is can you handle your mind can
you manage the thoughts and the emotions
that are trying to poison your progress
forget managing the situation
manage your mind
[Music]
training your mind to sit calmly
in the eye of the storm
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Grant Cardone on how to embrace
feared I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that I want to make sure
we're moving from watching the video to
actually taking action so I have three
questions no more questions for you to
think about after watching this video
write them down for yourself talk to a
friend about them or leave them in the
comments below
here they are question number one what
do you need to do every morning to start
your day with confidence
question number two what is the monster
under your bed that you need to face and
question number three what anchor
thoughts can you use to move from fear
into action thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
fear is the great indicator sooner or
later you will experience fear when you
start taking new actions at new levels
in fact if you aren't then you're
probably not doing enough of the right
things fear is it bad or something to be
avoided conversely it's something you
want to seek and then to embrace fear is
actually a sign that you're doing what
is needed to move in the right direction
what is fear anyway I mean really does
it even exist is it real
I know it feels real when you're
experiencing it but admit it most of the
time what you fear doesn't even occur
fear for the most part is provoked by
emotions not rational think chances are
that when you were a child you've found
fear in irrational things the boogeyman
under the bed for example adults have
their own boogeyman the unknown
rejection failure fear success and on
and on for example if you're afraid to
call a client then it's that sound you
should call that client fear of speaking
with the boss is an indication you
should march into his office and ask for
a moment of this time everyone everyone
experiences fear on some level the fear
doesn't just tell you what to do it also
tells you when to do it
ask yourself what time is it at any
point in the day and the answer is
always the same the time is now the time
is always now and when you experience
fear it's a sign that the best time to
take action is that very moment now the
only thing that will make a difference
in that moment of fear is action failure
comes in many forms it occurs whether
you act or you don't act regardless of
the outcome I would say it's far
preferable to fail while doing something
than to fail by over preparing while
someone else walks up and scoops up your
dreams fear is a sign to do whatever it
is you fear and do it quickly
altruistic world domination honey Empire
right I'm grateful I understand why I'm
here I think because I am so open I
wanted to think and see it's a bloody
brief life
all of you have the potential for
enormous success if you want to know
what garyvee DJ khalid oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video